you've seen the good version in wreck-it
Ralph you skip the Will Ferrel version
in mega mine now get ready for the most
ok version of the animated villian
becomes a hero story in Despicable Me 1
and to meet groove a terrorist who's
just likable enough to keep the audience
on his side he's got severe depression a
plan that will kill everyone on earth
steely come moon and a really funny boy
so you don't dwell too hard on those
things you will not cry or laugh or
giggle enter a world where villains and
spies lurk just below the surface or
rather right on top of the surface where
everyone can see where the evil plots
are straight out of Carmen Sandiego the
Great Pyramid of Giza had been stolen
and replaced by a giant inflatable
replica but the bad guys draw the line
at robbery I really don't see how we can
a fool up face I just get another loan
from the bank and the police straight up
don't exist which is too bad because GRU
kills a lot of people
[Music]
in despicable me right along as GRU
adapts three little girls with three old
grammar names Margo Edith and Agnes in
this short but sweet kids movie with
heart and humor then watch Despicable Me
2 a 90-minute rehash of the first one
with more of what kids really want
minion fart jokes get it
the minion did the fart noise see Pixar
this is exactly what was missing from up
witness the tragedy of a man slowly
losing his franchise to his underlings
as the minions go from cute little
interludes between scenes to having
their own pee story to getting a
spin-off movie that's bigger than the
despicable means ever were to becoming
the unofficial mascot of your crazy
aunts Facebook page what do the minions
have to do with vaccines what is wrong
with you aunt Pam so kick back and enjoy
the franchise you love to hate not
because the movies are bad but because
you can't get away from the ad campaigns
the crappy spin-offs or that Pharrell
song you liked it first until it
burrowed into your brain like a moly
soak tapeworm
[Music]
the folks we truly
then it's back in my head again starring
Orthodox groove what your vector Victor
Professor Farnsworth DJ Stephanie and
Michelle L Mexican stereotype Oh black
we go the orphanage where Bruce Wayne
gets all of his Robbins probably and
Tony Homer Simpson heads Despicable Me
unions
hey you still that nacho had from The
Simpsons
you don't own everything yellow and bald
you know pay screen junkies if you want
even more Despicable Me watch us show
Steve Carell Kristen Wiig and the cast
of the movie some real despicable means
on this week's screen junkie show click
below to check it out
when the snows fall and the white winds
blow the lone wolf dies but the pack
survives the emoji movie will be the
greatest movie ever made
sarcasm Carmen Sandiego and Waldo made a
movie together now you just have to find
it I am a proud metrosexual attack
helicopter